[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about
whatever we want dick faces
thick faces you know what i was really
surprised of
so um i wanted a workout this morning i
did find this crossfit gym in our city
that was open so i went to go work out
there
and it was like 6 a.m you wanted to
change like you're like i'm getting i'm
leaving the house
so you went to a different gym well i
didn't have enough weights at home
oh do i want to do dallas and stuff and
then so i went to this
this crossfit gym and then i went inside
and i saw a bunch of kids in there
and i'm like oh [ __ ] these kids are up
early at 6 a.m i'm like hey guys how
come like you guys are training this
early and goes well
you know like we can't really go to high
school but we still want to be good at
football
and i'm like damn there's like kids that
are just like still dedicated even
they're pivoting with the times
damn i was lazy as [ __ ] at that age yeah
they look like you don't like those kids
that are like they have the body of an
nfl football player but they're 15 right
here yeah
they look like those kids how is that
even possible man these kids are
dedicated
wasn't the team no it wasn't the team
you can kind of tell like you know on
the team you have the people that are
like
really care about it they want to take
it far those that are [ __ ] around and
i think those are the ones that
at the home weight room they probably
would have been the ones that are
training their ass off anyways
have you ever watched hard knocks no
it's a show about
nfl training camp yeah but point being
those people
that you're talking about who spent all
that time many years yeah they maybe
never even get to play a snap
of an nfl game wow like where are they
playing that's what are they trained for
then
no they're they're hoping to get for
that one
on a football team but then you hope to
get on the nfl team that's even more
elite but then you hope to actually play
a game on the nfl team
make the roster that's hard as [ __ ] so
what is what is the
what is yeah what is it like thousands
of applicants right
and then like what are the like cause
they're like there's like d-league and
all that physical [ __ ] freaks we're
talking about like
[ __ ] human refrigerators who can also
run a 4-3-5 which is like
in a 50-yard dash you run in for like
sprinters
yeah that are in a refrigerator box
exactly but also how resilient you are
so there are people that are like okay
freshman sophomore
insane prospect crazy like field iq
extreme specimen runs the craziest
but takes one hit from the side blows
out their acl exactly
then there's another guy who can
repeatedly get hit by trains and they
just pop off to feel like it's nothing
so it's like
the freakiest of the freaky where you
have not only
yourself are you a athletic specimen but
you're also able to get run over over
and over dude or you're you're a
phenom in college you're colt mccoy
you're a tim tebow colt mccoy
you get to the nfl as as bart knows and
you suck
and that's what's wild too some guys get
stage fright for some reason yeah dude
so you could be a phenom where
everyone's like you're the guy you
already made already gatorade wants you
everybody wants you
and you're still [ __ ] why is it that i
hear
from um football as being like an
extremely hard
like like there's hella competition and
then it's like they only recruit
very very little throughout the year
where i don't really
i know it's competitive in other sports
but i always hear it in football
way more than the other ones because the
contracts are way higher in the nfl
and the there's 53 people on a team and
so
it's highly highly competitive so
there's 32 teams and 53 people per team
but aren't basketball teams uh less
people that's true basketball has less
players best players
and not as lucrative either not as big
football market-wise
they're huge well football contracts are
big but they're they're
they're fickle they're like oh they're
strong if you're out you're out there
yeah
it's not like baseball contracts where
it's like lifetime yeah
but like patrick mahomes just signed for
half a billion dollars
is he like the highest the highest paid
exactly
five million dollars i think it's like a
six or seven year contract but he's the
starting quarterback for the chiefs
and that's unfucking heard of whereas in
baseball there are huge contracts too
it's like 200
some 50 mil and all that kind of [ __ ]
for a pitcher i feel like the
quarterbacks are the ones that usually
get those big deals right they are yeah
they're the generals of the team
they don't even know if baseball is a
real sport if you wear pants
explain yeah like what sport do you wear
pants
and football football is pants yeah are
they pants
do you consider them not pants because
they're tight to the knee they're like
leggings yeah you're
not wrong they're not pin stripe slacks
but their butts look good
they did they have the [ __ ] rock run
[ __ ] fast too i would say
they look like knights yeah they're dope
so okay like basketball contract or
soccer contract or whatever or do people
not care about soccer because it's
worldwide and not american because they
they
very lucrative too very lucrative i mean
the most uh well-paid
athlete is cristiano christina yeah
ronaldo yeah
i think he tops the list every single
year yeah how much do they
try to chase his ass and on the forbes
list
handsome as [ __ ] at the same time true
he gets money you know aside from sports
he also gets money from [ __ ]
you play soccer and he wears his [ __ ]
underwear and [ __ ]
so but mahomes got half a billion just
to play for the chiefs
we're not talking about endorsements
like he's he's already in state farm
commercials with aaron rodgers like it's
crazy even more yeah
that is crazy i saw this list like [ __ ]
like over five years ago right
and they're saying um well mayweather
was the top
paid athlete because he owned his own
company
and all that so he was like number one
by far
but then after that it was like some
boxers and then like
de la hoya too for a bit yeah he was up
there it was like there's anything like
boxers like boxing has a lot of [ __ ]
money in it
and then there's like um some basketball
at lebron yeah because they they have
endorsements and other things and other
assets that they
like diversify in true yeah but i was
like pretty
interested in that whole world because
you
one individual playing a game
is a whole company like and you make
more than some countries
and i'm like can you imagine that like
you you're worth
shooting the ball kicking something
that is it that's that's your [ __ ]
product but that's how
elite these are i know that's crazy
automatic
like check this out i'm gonna shoot this
a hundred times if no one guards me 99
are going in exactly yeah that's what's
crazy get a jump shot
at the buzzer like game five of the
playoffs
last second and i'll make it yeah don't
like play the gatorade commercial right
when i do this
bank on me bam right now play the
gatorade card to the guy in the stands
who's like oh [ __ ]
you know but then you know how it has
that uh normalizing effect where like
so for example right the nba dudes are
freaking tall
but because they're all tall they all
look normal
until you see them in person and you're
like what the [ __ ]
i never seen so many giants in my life
you see a small guy
in person you're like what the [ __ ] even
mugsy bugs like you both would be like
whoa
yeah did you see the reference of like
how kevin hart is with the rock and how
the rock with is with shaq and with shaq
and yao min
oh yeah so yao ming makes shaq look like
rock and heaven kevin hart did you see
the roast of justin bieber
where kevin hart is the host and then
who went up to roast
[ __ ] well anyway someone went up to
roast and they were like man i don't
know jack was there too
yeah he's like i don't know that um this
show is gonna be hosted by shaq's dick
[Laughter]
really funny and then and the snoop dogg
was there
and then they're like snoop looks like
shaq skeleton
that rose is really good skinny
that that size difference man it blew my
freaking mind because
i didn't know yao ming was that big how
tall is he lightning six
okay oh he's one of the most
tallest nba player of all time you live
shorter when you're bigger
like taller just because i think so yeah
like the heart it comes more
like a great day you remember the guy
who played jaws in 007
who played john do you remember the
metal mouth he played jaws with roger
moore and all those all that all those
it doesn't matter
he did he was very yeah yeah the giant
very very tall he actually lived a long
time
for the for most giants like he was like
60 or something when he died
damn yeah there was this kid on tick
tock two that we saw um like they do
these little snippets like here's my
life and then they introduced the mom
and the dad
and the mom i mean the dad was like six
seven the mom is six
two and then he's like seven something
yeah like he had to like duck under
every door sports
he played basketball but i mean he
didn't go into his life
being that big where you're born and you
already don't fit on the hospital bed
god right you're like what the [ __ ] do i
do remember when shaq did
mtv cribs or something and we saw a
brown bed
it just looked like a floor remember his
wife who was like 5'4
yeah she's like she's like yeah he slams
me
he slam [ __ ] me every night
oh god i just need a friend
her hoops what was her name from flavor
of love do you know mary is the second
night
that might have been that might be his
girlfriend yeah but like they would
stand together she's like right by his
waist
i'm like what the [ __ ] do you do with
that i remember i was at like foot
locker
and then they had shaq's like shoe there
it was just chilling there and i was
like wait a minute it's
this is his actual foot size
i remember i was a kid his size twenties
like it was like this [ __ ] big though
the clown shoe for us yeah i was like
are you how does he drive me
with his dick on the dash oh i heard he
actually uh
sits in the he has like a custom theme
where he sits in the back seat takes out
the front seat and drives from the
backseat damn how much money does that
cost
a lot but if you guys aren't in a
financially good situation let
upstart help you because you're
sponsoring this podcast during these
tough times everyone is looking for a
way to feel more
financially secure and if you're still
throwing money away
every month at high interest credit card
debt it's time you checked out upstart
the revolutionary online lending
platform that knows you're more than
just a credit score now is the time to
find out
how low your up start rate can be to
help pay off all that high interest
credit card debt because if you don't
it compounds and then you'll never pay
it off i actually used the same exact
method to
clear out all of my credit card debt
right after college i had like 40 grand
it was like 16 plus percent apr
it was just i was like there's no way
with the compounded issues i'm gonna be
able to pay this off so
luckily i was able to consolidate and
find another creditor that i can just
get for a way lower apr so use this
method it's really awesome so it's
unlike other lenders
too where upstart can reward you based
on your education
and job history and it's in the form of
a smarter rate
but you don't need a degree or diploma
to apply i wish i freaking had something
like this
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online
they offer loans from 1 000 to 50 000
so you can consolidate your debt into
one easy fixed
payment cy upstart has a four point nine
out of five rating on trustpilot in a
hurry to upstart.com
record that's r-e-c-o-r-d to find out
how low your upstart rate can be
so if you can consolidate all those
bills the less bills you have
the less tracking of the the less you
have to keep track of checking your rate
only takes a few minutes that's
upstart.com
record r-e-c-o-r-d can you believe that
michael jordan
like gets paid now more to not play
basketball than he did to play
basketball that's amazing you get paid
yeah
i know he's an owner shoe company shoe
company
is he still got haynes or is that like
um
yeah we don't even know the back inner
workings you know well a lot of
entertainers and athletes and stuff like
that when they become even more
rich it's because they have products or
businesses or they diversify their
income and investments and [ __ ] like
that
like dre for example i think he was one
of the first
rap billionaires or whatever because he
had beats by dre
well like how 50 cent was invested into
vitamin water and he
built his wealth like even bigger that
way
and i think um even with youtubers right
like
uh we have jeffree star who's like not
really balling off of his youtube
channel
even though he is yeah he's he's doing
he's murdering it and and and yeah
makeup
yeah yeah his house is huge
yeah so it's like products and things
like that i think that's where the real
wealth is or like yeah i just miss
mtv cribs because you brought it up i do
miss it why did they take it down
like family fair does a thing on youtube
where they still have celebrity home
but it's not the same it's not mtv
though i like the format they still do
the jokes though like this is where it
all happens sometimes
oh [ __ ] off i hate that one this is
where the magic turned into youtube's
like what's in my car
yeah it feels more like that yeah i like
when they're like oh
what are you doing here come on in guys
it speeds up
oh yeah like walk through they zoom
through their house yeah i just watched
one with scottie pippen
and he was taking it through his house
and he has a court with his jersey on it
and [ __ ] well tight that's pretty sick
you know i i heard through
the uh the [ __ ] jordan documentary
how like
uh scottie payne was underpaid but
looking at that video i'm like
[ __ ] he did just fine he's okay more
true
he was helping his family oh yeah he was
helping pay like his family and all that
stuff
he's still rich as [ __ ] though i felt so
bad throughout the entire
[ __ ] documentary for him i heard that
like
that's a pretty big deal for a lot of
people when
um you become a little wealthy right
like
family members friends although they
just want your help or support or
help me with my car payments invest in
their business idea or whatever
and i'm like thank god i don't have
family members like that
no leeches in your life well one of my
family members
was like oh you're gonna move vegas
don't buy me a house
i'm like no mom i'm not gonna buy you
thank god i don't have a materialistic
family either like
they like take pride in being like well
[ __ ] money
and i'm like that's dope like we just
want to hang out at the beach with you
and i'm like that's
tight my dad literally has his like
entire financial plan
uh worked out based off of his longevity
so you know he has those eight costco
shoes right yeah
so he goes okay i got my shoes covered
until my death
uh he goes i have just eight yeah he
goes i only need those
um he goes i probably will only drive
one more other car besides this one
before i die
and then he has and he already has like
you know he has those uh white v-necks
that are stretched out with holes in it
yeah
he has like a couple more packs of them
that are brand new and he goes
i'll probably be able to wear these
packs before i die
and everything is just planned out for
the rest of us you know i've never seen
your dad wear any
anything other than the v-neck white
that'll stretch the phone yeah and then
sometimes suspended
costco shoes i've never seen him wear
you should get a different wardrobe
he's a man of habit like this guy i
lived
with him and he is a routine master that
doesn't need
anything to help him with his memory he
doesn't need to stimulate he'll be like
all right i'll see you on friday at 6 00
pm
and he hangs up right or like he never
uses gps or whatever
and somehow like clockwork tuesday at
this time
[ __ ] they have the steam cleaner i
have to put this on
you know it's just he's just like a
robot he has like a thomas guide built
into his brain
somehow like he knows la like i don't
know like as if he was born here
and then if you go like hey okay i'll
see you uh april 26th
and then he doesn't write it down on
april 26 he shows up where he's supposed
to go
he never writes anything down i never
seen him go okay let me take notes
imagine he secretly does
he's like
[Laughter]
he's a cocky waiter yeah i think he said
he's
cocky waiter i always kind of go when
they [ __ ] up i'm like
i want you to [ __ ] up i want you to
[ __ ] wrote it down [ __ ]
oh i said i said grilled chicken
sandwiches gonna be not grilled we'll
see
but some restaurants actually don't want
you to write [ __ ] oh really
yeah why i mean it just looks more
professional like yours
yeah like the upscale restaurants they
recommend you
as a waiter not to write it yeah if i
get worried though if i knew it was one
of those i'd be like
yeah can i get the grilled chicken
sandwich one pickle
but they also at those upscale
restaurants only have like 10 items
true i thought i could be a cocky waiter
when i worked as a waitress for my
uncles
spot when i was 15. and because there
was only like
five items on the menu or something like
that but they can get customized so i'm
like
i could totally remember this because
all of the orders were just easy it'd be
like
whatever it is right so then i'm like
cool got it but then sometimes we get
so [ __ ] busy and i'm going to all
these tables and nobody else
none of the other waitresses used any
like we did have pads where we could
write
you didn't want to be the one waiting to
have to write it down and then i'm like
[ __ ] and then spanish is my second
language so or like
technically first but you know at 15 i
was not a pro at it so i'm like trying
to
communicate with the with the customers
and i'm over here like i'm so sorry can
you tell me again
what's your order oh my god [ __ ] so then
i would get the shittiest tip
not a professional one no it was bad my
pride got in the way because i'm like
wait no no one else is doing it like i
don't want to [ __ ]
that's why they got those burger spots
where i'm like wait
isn't that kind of redundant but i see
because they don't want to mess up the
order
where like the guy's right here with the
mic and the cooks like right behind them
and goes can i get a burger down
two burgers down i'm like uh do you want
me to just tell the cook myself because
he's literally like right behind you
you're gonna be like he's like literally
like right there that's funny
what's with every drive-through now
having a person outside with a [ __ ] i
love it
do you really work here yeah i'm like it
could have been anyone that walks up to
you
i'm like your badge and he's like
there's the chick-fil-a i'm like all
right
wait how far out is your guy is he like
two streets down
he's far away he's right outside his
house
sir have you ever been to chick-fil-a
there's a [ __ ] line going down
two blocks easy that's true oh maybe
even your neighborhood because it's
popping
dude i was like krispy kreme at midnight
and it was cracking dude
they had to have a line control dude for
the [ __ ] uh drive-through
they had cones he was sitting there and
he would like direct
traffic and [ __ ] man it took me like 30
minutes to get through
damn you still sat there to get those
done i was stuck that's the fattest
thing you can
i can think of it's at midnight
yeah and waiting an hour and the light
was on the fattest thing you've ever
been
on fresh donuts coming out yup
i wonder if that's the place like that
one place at night where there's
actually peace during protests
where people are doing both sides like
you know it'd be really good right now a
donut
so you have people like antifa on one
side and like the other people on the
other side
it's kind of like british people british
soldiers during tea time
right yeah like they'll be fighting and
they'll be like hold halt time for some
grey yeah teas and crumpets
like oh i thought you were really
actually injured over there
like samurais they're like tea time and
then they go into the tea house
and then they [ __ ] share matcha yo
they did a [ __ ] cease fire during
world war one we talked about that yeah
and they're like let's have a christmas
party
and then they're like all right wow
tomorrow pretty much
that's crazy dude we'll start shooting
at each other after jingle bells
jingle bells everybody ready to go
i love how the song starts immediately
after the announcement
[Music]
you